bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france acquis
les pays européens achètent ils le gaz
écoutez ils achètent leur gaz à divers
pays producteurs et parmi ces pays
producteurs d'un des principaux
fournisseurs c'est la russie puisque la
russie fournit à peu près de 100
milliards de mètres cubes par an c'est à
dire 40 % de ce que les pays européens
achètent alors évidemment ce pourcentage
varie d'un pays à l'autre il est plus
important pour des pays qui appartenait
auparavant au bloc de l'est puisqu'il
faisait partie de la politique
énergétique soviétique
il est beaucoup moins important pour des
pays qui ont une politique très
diversifié qui ont des ressources
nucléaires importantes comme la france
et puis l'allemagne et bien l'allemagne
importe 40% de ce qu'elle achète de la
russie et ce pourcentage va augmenter
dans les prochaines années puisque
l'allemagne a prévu de sortir
complètement du nucléaire
dès l'année prochaine et de sortir du
charbon en 2035 par conséquent ses
besoins énergétiques en gaz vont
augmenter et ce pourcentage augmentera
et c'est bien pour ça que l'allemagne
est le pays le principe allemands
intéressés par north stream 2 la france
a diversifié j'ai dit ces moyens
d'approvisionnement
d'abord en gaz naturel liquéfié puisque
la france a trois ports qui peuvent
accueillir des méthaniers et qu'elle
sert même de plate forme de relais pour
fournir du gaz naturel à l'espagne à
l'italie et à la suisse donc c'est un
système un peu plus diversifiée
d'ailleurs des ports de ce genre là
l'allemagne cherche à s'en doter
alors l'achat de gaz
alors ici va-t-il créer une dépendance
bien sûr il va créer une dépendance
mais cette dépense elle s'exerce dans
les deux sens c'est la dépendance du
client qui attend les livraisons de gaz
qui l'a achetée et c'est la dépendance
du fournisseur qui attend le paiement
c'est-à-dire les recettes de
l'exportation en devises
par conséquent cette double dépendance
c'est ce qu'on appelle une
interdépendance et je vais vous dire
vous donner un exemple puisque la france
a l'habitude de se fournir en russie et
même à l'époque soviétique il y à 45 ans
la france a signé son premier accord de
fourniture à long terme de gaz de gaz à
l'époque de gazprom est effectivement
pendant toute cette période et jusqu'à
maintenant il n'y a jamais eu de
problèmes de livraison parce que c'était
l'intérêt de gazprom
c'était l'intérêt de gazprom de
fidéliser son client et même à la la
pire époque de la guerre froide et bien
les livraisons se sont fait tout à fait
naturellement
c'est donc la création d'une
interdépendance et assez souvent on dit
que l'interdépendance par les échanges
commerciaux c'est une garantie contre
les conflits armés
finalement cette question le projet
north stream 2 verra-t-il le jour
je pense que oui puisque sur les 1200 30
km que fait cette liaison sous la
baltique
il en reste à peu près 6 ou 7 % donc
assez peu que les travaux ont été
suspendus pendant une année puisque les
entreprises et qui participaient étaient
menacés par les états unis de sanctions
très grave donc de sanction
extraterritoriale chose qui est tout à
fait inacceptable pour les pays de
l'union européenne
comment leurs entreprises pourraient
elles être sanctionné par les états unis
pour un projet qui est parfaitement
légal du point de vue du droit
international
donc les travaux ont repris et vont se
poursuivre et probablement aboutir assez
vite dans le courant de l'année 2021
évidemment
les états unis vont sans doute tout
faire pour empêcher ce projet d'aboutir
à bonne fin une sorte de course de
vitesse est engagée
un certain nombre de précautions ont été
prises puisque l'un des arguments c'est
vous augmentez la dépendance vis-à-vis
de la russie je viens de dire que c'est
pas tout à fait exact puisque c'est une
interdépendance en réalité mais l'autre
argument c'est que ceci va faire baisser
les revenus de transit du gaz qui
passait à travers l'ukraine puis un
gazoduc anciens de l'époque soviétique
qui traversent l'ukraine est en effet
une partie du gaz russe qui est importé
dans les pays de l'union européenne
passe par ces élèves hugues ancien et
l'ukraine reçoit des droits de péage qui
sont assez importants mais il ya
exactement un an avec une médiation de
la commission européenne la russie et
l'ukraine ont conclu un accord qui
garantit à l'ukraine que pendant cinq
ans et bien au moins 40 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz passons par ses
tuyaux et que par conséquent ceci lui
assurera un revenu budgétaire d'environ
7 à 8 milliards de d'euros
donc c'est un autre sujet qui est plus
ou moins calme et puis souvent un traité
pour le reste évidemment au fin du fin
les états unis veulent que les pays de
l'union européenne achètent leur gaz
naturel liquéfié puisqu'ils sont un
excédent avec l'exploitation du gaz de
schiste
et après tout pourquoi est ce que
l'allemagne d'autres pays n'achèterai
pas un peu de gaz liquéfiés américain il
est plus cher puisqu'il faut liquéfié et
il faut leur gazéifiée après la
traversée de l'atlantique
pourquoi pas mais actuellement le marché
gazier est excédentaire et puis les
opérateurs ce ne sont pas les états ce
sont des entreprises privées
merci beaucoup à vous claude
blanchemaison je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales